emails have been pouring into me about
bitcoin and increasingly about ethereum
uh the big news this week bitcoin
recently hitting a new record high above
69 000 us dollars per coin this is
happening at the same time that
inflation numbers have surged and there
are now
even more signs that cryptocurrency is
being mainstreamed and may well be here
to stay now as many of you know i have
taken a very what i consider a very
middle-of-the-road approach on
cryptocurrency i have said basically
since um
since 2016
i have owned
some cryptocurrency
mostly
bitcoin and ethereum and occasionally
others at different times
i have said i have no idea what the
value of these things is going to be in
the future
but as they have survived
as the number of transactions has
increased
and as their value has gone up that has
certainly been a factor
i have become more and more of the
mindset that having some portion of
assets in this asset class
is logical
for me
not saying it for anybody else
and whether that's three five six
percent
when the big spikes have happened my
exposure on crypto has surged to seven
eight percent but then i sell down i
take profits and sell down
that's been my approach and over the
last few months we've seen the launch
of institution sort of legacy financial
companies start to offer cryptocurrency
etfs
we've seen mainstream financial
advisorships say
hey
this might be something you want to hold
and now
we are continuing to see signs that this
is here to stay and i'm going to give
you my outlook on that momentarily i do
want to mention
that this particular video was sponsored
by policy genius if there's someone who
relies on you for financial support
might be a child might be a parent could
be a business partner or spouse
it's often important to have life
insurance when you buy life insurance
there's a feeling of relief you know the
people in your life are covered if
something happens to you
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place you could save thirteen
hundred dollars or more a year on life
insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies it's quick and easy you
do it at
policygenius.com david pakman show it's
like two to three minutes and you can
see how much coverage do you need
compare quotes find the best price and
when you're ready to sign up policy
genius will set it up for you for free
they've earned thousands of five star
reviews on trustpilot and google they
don't sell your information life
insurance generally is pretty affordable
for most people and with thanksgiving
coming up you might have down time it's
just a couple of minutes so
policygenius.com
david pakman show and get started
there is a perfect storm happening right
now
that could lead to even further
cryptocurrency adoption
i'm not predicting that
i'm exposing my portfolio to the
possibility that that happens by holding
cryptocurrency as you know
um tim cook the ceo of apple recently
said i hold some cryptocurrency and have
for some time and for better or worse
right or wrong accurately or not
accurately the fact that inflation
continues to be a news story is pushing
people to adopt cryptocurrency now you
might say hold on a second david sir
that doesn't make any sense uh
the inflation is transitory uh this is
not about the devaluation of the that's
fine
there's no that that may actually be the
case i'm not saying it's logical
i'm saying it's happening that the
narrative and the stories about
inflation and increased cost of some
goods and services
seems to be hyping people to push over
to cryptocurrency as well so i continue
to not know anything i don't know where
tesla stock will be in a year i don't
know where bitcoin will be in a year i
don't know
my decision has been
i want to at least have some exposure to
what has been one of the asset classes
with the most explosive growth over the
last 10 years
i don't want to be shut out of that
but i want to do it responsibly with a
percentage of my assets that feel safe
because it is speculative it is
speculative that's my view right now
curious to hear your thoughts i know
there's a lot of pro crypto people in my
audience a lot of anti-crypto people in
my audience leave your thoughts down in
the comments